what's going on everybody welcome to the
fourth SQL plus Python tutorial video
and actually my sequel plus Python
tutorial video where we left off I was
showing you guys how to kind of manually
do some stuff and now let's go ahead and
get into the Python Python situation so
what we want to do now is I'm going to
go ahead and kill this little console
that's what we've been working in and
since we're really strapped for CPU
performance we want to go ahead and kill
our and now also actually I bet we can
even open another console I think I
think three accounts only have a one in
console limit so close that anyway uh so
the next thing we want to do is let's go
ahead and let's go to files because if
you run this it will open up a Python
the console and actually we want to go
into files and I want manually edit a
file so come down here and we're going
to make a new file name again if you're
on like some other server uh you know
make a file and put up the yeah you can
do this on your computer and like click
and drag the file into here but for now
I'm just going to make this DB connect
example dot PI so now when you make that
comes here and so it's just very much
like an idle or any other IDE that we're
going to use so now what we want to do
is import my sequel DB now again one of
the great things about Python anywhere
is they've got like a billion modules
pre-installed so you can just get like
you can kind of rest assured that
whatever you're going to import they're
going to have it but even if they didn't
you could install it and you can also
click and drag like your own modules in
but anyway they have my sequel DB
pre-installed anyway so you don't worry
about getting it now we want to open up
a database connection so we're going to
do con for connection equals and this is
going to equal my SQL DB connect and
again just pay attention to the case in
there and in here normally you could do
something like localhost in here but
with Python anywhere you can but just
for the record you could
with Python anywhere but we have to
connect to is my SQL server and just for
the record there as far as like figuring
out where that is you would go you can
click on dashboard and databases I think
it's got it listed here just in case you
ever forgot you could like look here and
so you can see your database username
that there you can change your database
password and you can look at your
existing databases here anyway back to
the script that's what we want to
connect to the next thing you throw in
here is your username right and again
your username is here mine's a beginner
account I'm just going to copy that and
pop over here and just paste that bad
boy right in there the next thing is
your password my password is cookies so
that's that the next thing I want to do
is you say what what database you want
to connect to not your table database
and again database is your username so
mine is going to be a beginner account
dollar sign and then the name of that
database and if you forgot you could
always just pop over here but mine is
tutorial so pretty easy to remember that
one
so tutorial now just like let's see we
got to close off this and we're all set
we're back to not work not needing
semicolons this isn't great okay anyway
C equals and C is short for cursor just
in case an boys curious and that's going
to conduct cursor so if you couldn't
have figured it out now you know so
that's that next we're going to run C
dot execute and this is how we can
execute a query sometimes you'll see
people like literally like right in like
SQL and that's going to equal like
variables but instead I always just
throw it in to execute and like later on
I'll show you how you can do it with
variables that way as well and you have
to worry about doing SQL this doesn't
really matter it's just a matter of
preference really and also if you'll
notice everything that we're doing here
I do have SQLite tutorials it's the same
syntax base like once you've imported my
sequel DB and you said that it's my
sequel DB connect everything's like the
same so anyway moving on anyways so the
execute is this is where we put in a
sequel query right so this will be
select all
Toula I mean this is you know nothing
new and now this is going to be rows
equals c dot fetch all so basically what
are all in just get all the results and
then four and then we're just can say
port each row in rows what do we want to
do let's just for now print each row you
can obviously do all kinds of things
with this data this is all we want to do
for now so let's go ahead and hit save
and run
that should pop up another console for
you and it should run it so as you can
see we did return the data here and this
is our integer this is our username
course and this is the tweet you should
recognize as whatever you put in and
just take note that it did return it
like this is a l for a long just for
anyone that's curious uh so anyway
that's just the basics now so now you
should be able to be comfortable with
working with my sequel you should know a
lot of the queries now like this is the
execute query in the next video I'll
show you guys how to work with some
variables and probably in that next
video we'll connect it to at least
Twitter and start streaming some tweets
into our database through Twitter so
anyways if that sounds interesting to
you guys stay tuned for those videos as
always thanks for watching thanks for
the support of the subscriptions and
until the next video